cpr can help save a person's life if
their heart stops if performed
immediately after a sudden cardiac
arrest cpr could more than double
someone's chance of survival i'm joined
by mike smith from the american heart
association to show us how to correctly
administer hands-only cpr on an adult
child and infant mike if someone is
having a sudden cardiac arrest what is
the first thing that you should do
absolutely so as i approach the patient
i want to make sure the scene is safe so
that's safe for me to enter so i would
come up and i would tap and shout hey
hey are you okay are you okay
hands-only cpr there's two basic steps
call 9-1-1 and push hard and fast in the
center of the chest so i would have
9-1-1 started and then i'm going to
start pushing right in the center of the
chest right in the middle of breastbone
pushing down about two at least two
inches
and at a rate of 100 to 120 beats per
minute think of the song staying alive
by the bee gees and that would be the
song in your head to do this
compressions
staying alive staying alive
staying alive staying alive and i'm
going to continue doing compressions
until help gets there so that's why it's
so important to get 911 activated as
soon as possible right and again there's
no need for breathing that's correct at
this point uh if you're unable or
unwilling to breathe into a patient
something is better than nothing so we
would start compressions move the
oxygenated blood that's still in the
body around and then
help it be coming with a ems so and
outcomes from hands-only cpr have been
shown to be just as good as cpr
performance yes it's so important to get
bystander cpr started before
professional rescuers get there you can
actually double or triple the chance of
survival and quickly if we were to
perform breathing yes can you tell me a
little about the ratio absolutely so i
would do 30 compressions and then two
breaths so i would do 30 2 30 and 2 and
continue that um until help gets there
perfect and next we have a child
mannequin so if we were to see a child
have a sudden cardiac arrest sure how
would we approach doing cpr in a child
well the american heart association
association would recommend doing
breaths and compressions on children and
infants a child is considered from one
to puberty so that's underarm hair on
male or breast development on female and
because that child would be all shapes
and sizes and we're all shapes and sizes
you have the option of doing one hand or
two-handed cpr but you still want to get
down at least two inches at a rate of
100 to 120 beats per minute
and for any adult worried about injuring
a child breaking ribs is that something
that should be in the mind of someone
performing cpr yeah i i think a lot of
folks are concerned about oh i don't
want to hurt the child or anything like
that but it is so important to push down
about two inches on the child we're
acting as the pump we're pushing the
oxygenated blood through the body it's
just imperative that we uh we do that so
yes we want to push down at least two
inches and if we were to work in
breathing again we don't have to but if
we were to as recommended what would the
ratio be sure so if i was working by
myself as a one rescuer i would be doing
30 compressions and two breaths
alternating crescent breath if i had a
second rescuer with me we would change
that to 15 compressions and two breaths
and then alternate
as needed great
and then walk us through if we had an
infant uh with a witness to rest sure
absolutely so for infant
uh we recommend the american heart
association recommends having the cha
the infant on a table or a flat surface
above the ground it's a little bit
easier to work so and because
we don't have to push down as hard we
would use two fingers going down about
an inch and a half instead of two inches
and same rate of 100 to 120 beats per
minute
and working in breaths what would the
ratio be absolutely so if i was by
myself one rescuer i would be doing 30
compressions and two breaths if we were
working together again we would change
that ratio to 15 compressions two
breaths perfect so to summarize
hands-only cpr is two steps first call
9-1-1 and second push hard and fast for
adults with two hands in the center of
the chest at 100 to 120 beats per minute
to the tune of staying alive by the
beegees and for children use one or two
hands in the center of the chest at 100
to 120 beats per minute and for infants
the pressure isn't as hard use two
fingers in the center at 100 to 120
beats per minute
mike there may be an instance where
somebody has access to a defibrillator
and i know for a lot of americans they
may have never seen a defibrillator are
unsure about how to use it walk us
through exactly what you would do
if you had access to a defibrillator in
the setting of someone having a cardiac
arrest absolutely and yes they're all
over the place you can find them in
grocery stores airports casinos and that
and they're very simple to use so
for this model the first thing you want
to do in any aed is power it on because
the aed will actually talk to you
and tell you exactly what to do
so for this one it's telling me to place
the pads directly on the patient there's
pictures also of where you would place
the pads so you peel these off
and you would stick these exactly where
they tell you
and the machine is not going to move
forward until this is done so it's just
going to keep reminding you to do that
at that point i would now plug the pads
connector in
it's checking the patient it's checking
to see what rhythm the heart is in the
patient
so it walks you through everything
absolutely
shock advised
so now the machine is charging with
energy to deliver a shock so at this
point we want everybody clear so you may
have to say clear
a shock is indicated so we would say
clear we would shock the patient
and then we would go right back into cpr
again 100 to 120 beats per minute
pushing down at least two inches on the
adult
and we would do that and in two minutes
the machine the aed is going to want to
analyze again
and it'll tell you in two minutes
absolutely it will say hold i want to
check the patient again and it's
checking for the heart rhythm at that
point to assess if it needs to shock
that is correct
so at this point i would just continue
with compressions
perfect well it's very self-explanatory
it's easy and so people don't have to be
afraid to use a defibrillator if they
are able to use that's correct
excellent thank you so much no problem